you hoping to erase this whole narrative
about not winning a play on there oh for
sure you know that's
just when to go home right now you know
i want to win regardless i don't really
care about
what people got to say you know um i
only been in the playoffs twice you know
my young career you know other people
been in the league forever haven't
been in the playoffs at all but it is
what it is you know but definitely
trying to reach that narrative right
there that's the number one right now on
my mind
lamar jackson talking about the reality
that he's owen two in the postseason and
with each passing loss the narrative
grows and grows the distraction becomes
larger and larger just ask the bengals
from 2011 through 2015. but peter i
would have suggested a different answer
to lamar jackson when asked the question
about the playoff narrative i would say
it's already been debunked it's been win
or go home for the last five weeks we've
played five playoff games this year
we've we've been up against it and we've
won every single one of those games if
we lose it we're done
so
this isn't really the playoffs to us
it's just a continuation of what we've
been doing for the last month
yeah plus i you know i think mike look
everybody is gonna want to see lamar
jackson play well in the playoffs i
think
it would have been a different story
against the chargers two years ago or
against the titans last year would have
been a different story if lamar jackson
had played well in either one of those
games and he really didn't you know if
you play great and lose in some duel
you know
you lost that's that's just the way it
goes but he hasn't played well in those
games and so i look at
i look at things like you know peyton
manning was he 27 years old when he won
his first playoff game there's some some
number like that
but
i don't i i'm not going to say that if
lamar jackson hasn't won a playoff game
by the time he's
26 years old well he's no good or his
legacy has been written it hasn't his
career isn't even one third over for
crying out loud
and so look he's got to play and he's
got to play well there's no doubt about
it and you're right
he's played great
down the stretch of this season
when
he couldn't have known it five weeks ago
but you're right you know one loss and
it's very likely they wouldn't be
playing right now so that is what
if if i'm a ravens fan that's what i'm
focusing on my quarterback got us here
and the the challenge is
and the reality i believe is that with
each loss in the playoffs and then you
have 12 months until you get another
opportunity the narrative gets a little
bit larger and a little bit larger and
it gets harder the pressure is greater
to finally get that first win and the
sooner you get it the better the sooner
you get it you kill that narrative and
you can focus on winning your next
playoff game a week later and for the
ravens and for lamar jackson i think
that's the key especially for lamar
jackson because i think the pressure on
him not just to win but to to have a
better game than what we've seen in his
two playoff losses will be critical
and you throw in the fact peter that
they're on the road they're facing the
titans a team that beat the ravens in
baltimore in overtime it was a great
game 30 to 24 with a touchdown run by
derrick henry to ice it
it puts even extra pressure on the
ravens to settle this score and they are
going to be looking at those helmets and
thinking these are the guys last year
that knocked us out of the postseason
and i i hate using the term revenge
because all the titans did was their job
a year ago but
if you can use that to your advantage if
you can and this is the challenge for
john harbaugh more so than lamar jackson
how do you properly communicate to your
guys this week how do you get them in
the right mindset are they already there
and you don't really need to do anything
what do you do to get them ready to go
to tennessee as favorites they can't
even go in with a chip on their shoulder
because they're favorites how do you get
them
in the right place where they can go out
and take care of business that's gonna
be a challenge for john harbaugh
i i think i think the most interesting
line in this game
or
in the on this weekend is the ravens
being favored at tennessee
look you take away the the tennessee at
green bay game over the last what six
weeks
i mean
the ravens are the titans have looked
like 27 yankees for crying out loud
they've been unstoppable
and you know if anything compared to a
year ago mike
look derek henry is
is incredible you know he's already had
more 200-yard games in his career than
jim brown or barry sanders had in their
careers
and he's only 27 years old
so and and but the thing i look about
look at with tennessee is
look at ryan tannehill look at how much
better i think anyway he is than he was
a year ago
i mean
it's hard for me to imagine tennessee
playing at home being an underdog to too
many teams but that's a weird line to me
the defense i think is the problem with
tennessee and look at what the ravens
did last year or last week excuse me in
cincinnati 404 rushing yards and they
have been grinding it up all year long i
mean so much for
high-flying pass offenses you got the
titans who have derek henry with his
2027 yards you've got the ravens with
the three-headed monster of lamar
jackson jk dobbins and gus edwards mark
ingram isn't even a factor anymore those
three guys contributed to that
performance last week significantly
contributed to it with 404 yards that
this could just be ground and pound for
three hours it could be a two hour and
fifteen minute game
yeah
i think both teams want to play that way
mike and we'll see what happens but the
one thing about this game that really
fascinates me
is that i think both teams
can play both ways you want to get in a
scoring contest ryan tannehill uh you
know has got a great i think a great
receiver you know in brown he's got a
very good tight end johnny smith
you know and on the other side you could
see the ravens playing the exact same
way they're very happy with running the
ball 55 times if you let him do it
they're gonna do it but they're also
okay
if they need to get into a throwing
contest because they're confident as the
season is worn on they're more confident
in their passing game so
that's why i think this is really
i think it's the game of the weekend i
think it's so much fun
so interesting now you know in terms of
drama probably the cleveland and
pittsburgh is the game of the weekend
because of how weird the lead up to the
game is but just as far as a football
game goes i mean i love that tennessee
baltimore game
one big difference between this game and
their meeting in the regular season week
11 in baltimore calius campbell and
brandon williams available for the
baltimore ravens they weren't there the
last time around when derrick henry had
not not a high end derek henry day but
it was good enough to get it done and he
popped that run in overtime to pull off
the victory last year though in that
playoff game in prime time in baltimore
193 rushing yards for derek henry so
henry obviously the key piece of the
puzzle to the tennessee offense and he
has to be able to answer
what the ravens collectively do running
the ball and it really is strange to
think about
so much running
in an age where it's so much passing but
as chris sims said earlier this week
it's cyclical although he struggled with
cyclical and we had some fun with that
but it is cyclical and teams are
starting to recognize that as defenses
spread out to deal with passing offenses
and also we don't see as much tackling
as we used to in practice there aren't
padded practices the art of tackling is
lost in many nfl locker rooms
there's a there's a temptation and
there's a benefit and there's a reward
to running the football
look
in my in my opinion just i think there
are so many teams in the nfl this year i
almost think even though the numbers are
not gigantic
i think there are so many dangerous
running backs in football right now
and i don't just mean derek henry i mean
a bunch of different
style running backs you know you've got
the combination of of power with an
outside move of like nick chubb
uh and you know and kareem hunt you've
got the power game
of derrick henry you've got the
elusiveness of alvin kamara you've got
to sort of bang it but also be able to
get outside of dalvin cook there are so
many interesting running backs and so
many different styles right now that
people are getting and and mike
you're getting these guys with value
picks
i didn't say the words
saquon barkley or christian mccaffrey
those are and i certainly didn't say
leonard fournette
but you know those are the top ten
running backs that you just don't see
that you need to do anymore you know
alvin kamara way down in the second
round derek henry second round
so many of these picks you're noticing
just like receivers you can find really
good ones in the second round even you
know dk metcalf late in the second round
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports